[Music]
hey you guys welcome to my tomes of
terror show this is my little uh book
review
playlist that i have going on here i put
up one a week on mondays uh in case
you're new here so the book that i'm
talking about today uh this is a book by
sergio gomez now i actually this is the
second uh thing of his that i read if
you'll remember just a couple months ago
right back around christmas time i think
i reviewed one of his uh novellas which
was called the visitor
and i did it because it was kind of like
a christmas story it was like an alien
attack kind of thing like set around
christmas in a diner and um i did
actually enjoy that one quite a bit i
thought that it um
probably would have benefited from being
fleshed out more because it was quite
short and probably did need some editing
because there was a lot of grammatical
errors in it but overall like a pretty
good book but this one i had been
wanting to read this one for a while
because
a lot of um you know kind of other book
reviewers and stuff that i
follow on youtube had really highly
recommended this one and this one
actually came out i believe before the
visitor i think this came out back in
late summer of 2019 and a lot of people
covered this one uh so i finally got
around to reading it because it's
available on kindle unlimited so when i
saw it pop up i was like oh you know
might as well pull the trigger on that
one and this one is called camp
slaughter
now
uh the cover and the title should clue
you into the fact that this is
essentially i i wouldn't call it like a
a parody but it's a slasher like an 80s
slasher homage is what it is
so what you have is there's a prologue
in which a married couple who have been
married a long time and they're kind of
you know bored with one another or
whatever so they decide that they're
going to take this romantic getaway out
to uh supposedly the most isolated cabin
in pennsylvania
and they're going to go out there and
have a you know a little vacation or
whatever
not really knowing all that much about
this place other than you know it looks
really nice the price was right it's
isolated blah blah they're gonna go up
there and like spice up their marriage
so they get up they get out there and um
it will surprise no one this is a
slasher novel uh that they end up well
at least one of them ends up getting
horribly murdered the husband who was i
think his name is stephen he basically
just gets an axe to the face and is
dispatched like pretty quickly uh
whereas you're not entirely sure what
happens to the wife nadine because
that's kind of where it ends
so then we jump forward a year
and for the first probably third of the
book like i said other than the prologue
you're kind of setting up
all of the characters that are
inevitably going to go out to the same
cabin
so it's essentially like two different
sets of people
so you have your kind of obligatory
college age
group and there's a lot of them and i
can't remember all of their names
exactly because that was one thing i did
actually really like this book it's
super fun it's really fast-paced as i
said if you're into 80s slashers then
you will probably just love this because
as i said it's a lot of fun but i will
say that there are a lot of characters
which i guess they do that in slasher
movies and stuff like that too because
they need more you know more people for
the for the slasher to kill but but in a
book and this book isn't that short it's
probably like 350 pages something like
that maybe even a little bit longer
although i will say that it's a very
quick read i read it in
one sitting just in maybe two or three
hours so it really does fly by uh and
the pros is actually quite just no
frills but i think that really works
well for this type of story
so but i will say that there are a lot
of characters and it's kind of hard to
i mean he does make an effort to
give you some backstory on each one of
them um but a couple of them kind of
fall between the cracks because you
don't know as much about them but there
are a few like that you know where the
details are kind of filled in because
they do you know he does want to make
you like care about them before they get
killed off because
i'm sure this will not be that much of a
spoiler but because it's a slasher but
pretty much everybody gets dispatched
like without too much uh you know thing
about it
so the college age kids there's a bunch
of them there's like um but it's the two
main guys are
gavin and fred
and they're kind of like they've been
best friends for a really long time but
they've been kind of uh starting to
drift apart i guess because gavin is
more like wanting to
maintain that sort of party lifestyle
whereas fred is kind of like getting
older and more mature and wanting to you
know finish college and get a good job
and blah blah and get on with his adult
life so they're still hanging out but
you know there's still there's a little
bit of kind of distance growing between
them
also fred has a crush on this girl named
noel
and they've kind of been they're not
dating but they've been kind of like
hanging out and kind of like talking and
stuff so gavin says why don't you just
invite her up there i'm inviting a whole
bunch of people and it'll be really fun
they also end up inviting uh this other
girl named vanessa
and then another girl whose name i can't
remember and then one of them brings
like their douchey cousin whose name is
dalton which i do remember because they
made a point of saying he was named
dalton like in roadhouse which i thought
was very funny so that's why i
remembered that
but uh so there was that and then gavin
gets forced to take along his younger
brother wayne who was only 14
uh because wayne calls up the parents
and is like hey gavin's like going and
he's gonna leave me all by himself so
the parents like make him take uh take
him up there with him they also take
this other guy named fletcher who's like
the drug dealer guy he's the guy they
buy all the weed from and uh i saw one
review on goodreads it said he's
essentially shaggy from scooby-doo which
he kind of is he's kind of like the the
quintessential like laid-back
pot head
uh you know kind of kind of hippie dude
so he comes along as well so there's
that whole group going on
but then there's this other there's not
really a group because it's just two of
them
but it's this older guy named emeril and
a younger woman named molly and they're
business partners they have kind of like
a youtube show or some kind of podcast
or something like that where they
investigate uh paranormal stuff so he's
like a paranormal investigator and she's
like a documentarian so they work
together
and initially they uh get interested in
this area where this uh cabin is where
this all this stuff's gonna take place
or camp slaughter as it's called camp
slaughter is kind of like
at first it's it's kind of like
portrayed as like an urban legend
they're like well
you know over the years you know people
have gone up into this particular uh
isolated stretch of woods where there's
rumors that there used to be a camp up
there and some people have never come
back so as i said the uh you know the
couple from the beginning it's weird
because the couple from the beginning
obviously the dude got murdered and they
found him in the laying in the kitchen
with an axe in his forehead and they
didn't find his wife nadine uh you find
out what happens to her later on
but
it was in the news but i guess it wasn't
like a big enough deal for a lot of
people to have heard about it so
actually all the college kids they
didn't really hear about like one of
them like googled the place and was like
oh this couple like disappeared or they
didn't come back or actually no they
didn't find the um i was gonna say they
didn't find the um
the husband's body because
the killer uh and this is not a spoiler
because i think that's on it's on the
blurb of the book is a cannibal so he
always goes and you know he doesn't want
to waste the meat when he kills somebody
so uh he basically cuts them up and eats
them so they didn't actually find a body
they just found uh two they had gone up
there and they disappeared
so
camp slaughter is supposedly like this
urban legend supposedly these people go
up here and disappear don't come back
and nobody knows what happens to them
and there have been rumors circulating
that there is somebody out there a
cannibal that is uh every now and then
every time some you know whenever
somebody goes up there he goes and like
picks them off and then they never find
them again um and again this obviously
this rumor is going to turn out to be
true so the paranormal investigator and
the documentarian emerald and molly
they um initially want to go up there
and make a documentary about this camp
slaughter legend and emeril who is
actually like a very serious believer in
the paranormal thinks that there's
probably some kind of paranormal [ __ ]
going on up there too
and so he's basically wants to go
investigate that but then when they get
up there and start asking around like to
the locals and stuff that's when they
find out oh we think there's actually
like a serial killer out there who's
picking people off and eating them and
that's why they're never finding the
bodies at which point they're kind of
like okay now this got really
interesting so now we're gonna like try
and find out where this place is so they
kind of go through one of the locals
he kind of roughly knows where it is so
he kind of draws them a map i'm not
entirely sure like what
i guess this is supposed to be set in
like contemporary times but i do kind of
feel like yeah because a lot of them had
cell phones and stuff but just like in a
lot of more modern horror movies they
have to kind of take cell phones out of
the
out of the equation obviously because
you know otherwise things would be
resolved too easily so you know making
this uh area very remote where they no
one can get a signal
so there's that whole situation as well
so you kind of have these two things
going on so you have all the college
kids and they get up there and then they
kind of run into the paranormal
investigator team
and they don't really team up but
they're just kind of like um you know
they're talking to each other about what
the hell is going on
now while all of this is going on and
you're kind of jumping back and forth
between all the different characters
you're also
privileged to the viewpoint of
the actual
killer so
i don't know if it's a third it's
probably like a quarter of the book is
actually told from the cannibal's point
of view he's a guy named ignacio
and he goes by i can't remember what uh
what the spanish name was cause sergio
gomez is actually a mexican was born in
mexico but then moved to the united
states when he was young with his family
uh so his uh serial killer is named
ignacio he's real into like uh the whole
luchador thing uh so he likes masks but
he makes masks out of human skin uh so
he's very much like a leather face
type character um he also has a lot of
stuff going on with uh some jason
voorhees kind of action too in the sense
that he's really big like he's six foot
five and he's like um unnaturally strong
he also has like really really super
good hearing
and uh but he's not that bright he's a
little bit uh you know mentally
challenged i guess not to uh not to a
point where he can't
uh function because he does have kind of
like a job like i think he works as like
a janitor or something like that like in
a restaurant or a hotel or something
like that because they do have one scene
like that but you know he's not he he's
aware of his uh limitations though
because he'll he'll think to himself
it's like oh my brain doesn't work right
or something like that and he can't have
too many things going on at once because
you know he won't be able to figure them
out
now interestingly this he's kind of an
interesting character and it's
even though he's obviously a monster
you do kind of feel a little bit of
sympathy for him because
they do um you know sergio gomez does go
into kind of like his history where he
was raised in mexico um
his dad was like a drug dealer
and from the time that ignacio was a
little kid
um he was like seeing his dad
like enforcing you know people that
didn't pay him or whatever like he cut
off their fingers and [ __ ] like that so
little ignacio was seeing that
and uh i guess like the dad gets killed
and then he gets very close to the mom
and then the mom ends up getting getting
murdered and much like jason voorhees uh
ignacio keeps the head of his mom like
on a pole and almost kind of makes like
a weird like um like a shrine to her as
i said much like in um in friday the
13th part two is what i'm guessing that
was homaging i forgot to mention too
that i can't remember what the what his
spanish name was but he goes by
the name
what the hell was it uh it means many
faces uh so like i said much like
leatherface you know not only when he
kills somebody if he likes the look of
their face or he thinks their face is
like big enough to fit over his face
because i guess he's got kind of a big
face um then he'll cut the face off and
keep it and like make a leather mask out
of it so he can like switch him out and
again like leatherface he sometimes puts
makeup on him like to make himself look
pretty and things like that so uh so as
i said this is very much
and you know and this is gonna sound
mean but it's it's very much much a
pastiche but
it's supposed to be so it doesn't really
bother me all that much because yes even
though the killer is
a combination of
a lot of different movie
killers and a few real ones as well
because i think there's some ed gene
thrown in there there's some other [ __ ]
too but it's but that's okay i don't i
don't really mind and like i said i like
that sergio gomez is like playing with
all these kind of horror movie tropes
like slasher movie tropes and just
making a fun
you know like i said he's not even doing
like a meta type of thing or nothing
like that this is just a fun
straightforward slasher story that uses
elements from a lot of different slasher
movies so if you like that kind of thing
then you'll probably like this as well i
will say too that i thought it was
interesting and that was one thing i
kind of wish that this had been a little
more explored maybe it will be because i
think that sergio gomez has said that he
wants to write uh essentially like a
sequel to this because it is the end of
it is left open
uh if he wanted to write another one in
the same universe
and so maybe he'll explore this more
there is a paranormal aspect in this uh
in the sense that you know the
paranormal investigators that go up to
camp slaughter and they're investigating
it and stuff they're like the guy emeril
is apparently kind of has a lot you know
sensitivity to that and he senses that
there's like all these kind of spirits
out there of all the people that have
been murdered and ignacio the killer
many faces he sees ghosts so he and he
doesn't even really think it's all that
weird because like i said he's not
super bright so he doesn't seem like
aware that it's strange that other
people can't see them but he can see
them like he sees his mom he sees his
victims just kind of like hanging out in
the woods so he sees ghosts all the time
there's also one of the college students
i think it's noel actually
uh is it was oh the other girl's name
was brook that's right but i think it
was noel and a little bit of her
backstory is that prior to her like
maybe a year or two prior to her going
on this trip
um her sister who was 16 was killed in
an accident and so she's kind of dealing
with survivor's guilt and like being
like maybe the accident was my fault and
and so she actually does see her sister
and it's hinted that maybe like most of
the time it's a hallucination but then
like toward the end when she's in danger
and she's you know running away from the
killer there does seem to be a place
where the ghost of her sister does like
show up and actually like help her so
there's a lot of kind of there's like
little hints of paranormal stuff going
on here too which i like that because
you don't see that in a lot of slashers
and
you know as i said i kind of wish it had
been explored more because
you know the killer ignacio who's
actually like a pretty cool character
even though obviously he's a monster
because he just uh chops people up and
this is very gory by the way so if
you're not if you're not really because
it's it's kind of one of those movies
like i said just like friday the 13th or
something like that where part of the
fun
is
seeing the way in which these people get
get bumped off you know what i mean
because it's always like really really
gory like there's always you know arms
and legs being cut off heads being cut
off just all kind of crazy [ __ ] like
that so it's very very gory very bloody
but like i said you know very over the
top and fun in that sense
but i liked that
since ignacio was
you know such a you know such a
combination of
movie serial killers you know that we've
already seen
i thought it was actually like a cool
something that was more like original to
him that he could actually see ghosts
and i thought that that was i i thought
it was going to play into the story more
it does play into the story some but i
felt like it kind of played more into
the story like into the story more with
the victims rather than with him
um so i kind of hope that if he does
another one
because if he writes a sequel to this i
will totally read it because i actually
did have a lot of fun with this one i
kind of wish that that it would play
into the plot more the fact that ignacio
could see ghosts in the woods that the
woods were full of ghosts and you know
the ghost of his mom and stuff and i i
thought that was like a really cool
aspect of his character so i kind of
hope more is done with that
so as i said this is just it's not you
know it's not meta it's not a parody
it's not doing anything like that it's
just taking all the best [ __ ] that you
like about 80s slasher movies just
you know the tropes of it here's like
these college students there's skinny
dipping scene you know hot girl skinny
dipping there's you know a whole romance
subplot that doesn't work out there's
kind of like all this other stuff going
on so it's like a lot of stuff from
you know
from just regular slasher movies but
just done in a really really fun way
this is just a fun entertaining
gory
book and like i said don't get attached
to pretty much any of these characters
because they pretty much all get killed
and one thing too is that he killed and
i'm i think like i saw some people like
that didn't like this too much but i
kind of liked it because
i feel like sometimes in some types of
horror movies not so much slashers but
where you have like it'll be like a big
deal like when some of the like when
some of the characters get killed this
one it's he's very like unromantic about
it you know what i mean it's just kind
of like he doesn't care if it's a 14
year old kid or a hot girl or whatever
everybody's gonna get [ __ ] killed and
because the the killer doesn't really
care about it he just sees them as meat
and you know and they're in my woods and
i'm gonna kill them and eat them now one
thing that he does have too that i
forgot to mention but you know nadine
from the beginning like she was in the
prologue where her husband got killed
and then like it jumps ahead of year
she has actually been alive this whole
time because it turns out that ignacio
if he now and then like finds a a woman
like a victim that he likes
uh he keeps them now nadine she got had
her like legs cut up or just her feet i
think he cut off her feet and he keeps
her in a barn and he calls them his
barbies
now he doesn't like he doesn't seem to
have any kind of like sexual anything
like he seems very childlike
but he likes having these little
dolls around to play with
uh you know that he can put makeup on
and [ __ ] like that so one of the college
girls who comes there later i think it's
vanessa uh is a girl that looks
like his mom
so
that's another thing too is that nadine
who's been alive and chained in the barn
with no feet this whole time
um for like a year uh you know she's
worried because now she's gonna get
replaced because he's seen this other
girl and he's like i can't he's like my
brain doesn't work right enough to take
care of two barbies at once so i'm gonna
have to like get rid of this barbie and
he kind of feels like bad about it so
he's like i said he's a very interesting
character i don't want to go too far and
say he's like a sympathetic character
because obviously he's a serial killer
and cannibal but
he's so
childlike and he's so like not all that
smart
that he i mean he seems to know what
he's doing is bad but
he i don't know it's just he doesn't
seem to take it all that seriously i
guess he also seems to have a little bit
of and i got kind of a dexter vibe from
him too no well not i don't want to say
that because then you'll think oh it's
you know somebody that kills serial
killers he's not like that uh in the
sense that dexter always said like he
had like what did he call it like the
dark passenger or whatever yeah many
faces ignacio has that too and it's
almost kind of like he has a split
personality so like he has you know the
hymn that's sort of
childlike uh you know and kind of he's
still a killer but
not as much but then he has this other
side of him that sort of like flips into
so it's almost kind of like he has a
split personality a little bit so
there's that kind of whole thing going
on too so as i said if you're really
into 80 slasher movies
and you want to read a book that is
essentially like an 80s slasher movie
like in book form then you know then
this would be probably be right up your
alley as i said it's not doing anything
super original it's not nothing like
that it's just taking all the slasher
tropes and you know playing with them
you know and just making just a fun
quick entertaining read out of it and
honestly i had a really good time with
this i thought it was super fun and like
i said if he writes a sequel to this
then i will absolutely read that as well
so uh if you've read it let me know what
you thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this tomes of terror
i will see you guys on the next one
bye